il ya mon soir diagonale l'actualité
internationale du jeu d'échecs avec éloi
rolland jean françois rey loi bonsoir
stéphane bonsoir à tous amis internautes
donc on a de la chance est décidément
dans le monde des échecs ça c'est tout
le temps il ya tout le temps quelque
chose à raconter
et encore cette semaine beaucoup de
choses on enverra dans la news le
classement international et sorties etc
mais surtout donc quelque chose qui nous
intéresse nous français a priori plus
plus que le reste un match spécial
entretiennent macro et zoltan almasy oui
alors superbe match joué à z en hongrie
ce sera le sujet de l'événement de la
semaine
nous rappelons quand même l'émission en
trois parties la première partie ce sera
l'événement donc on commentera ce match
ce match bacrot almasy deuxième morceau
c'est la partie commenté donc ça sera la
partie almadies bacrot sans surprise et
3e troisième et dernière partie
d'émission c'est les news l'actualité de
la semaine donc vu et revu rapidement un
petit quart d'heure alors tout de suite
on passe à l'événement de la semaine
voilà l'événement de la semaine donc ce
match bacrot almasy en hongrie qui s'est
jouée dans la ville de szeged tu connais
bien ce de ville tu m'as dit que tu y
étais allé déjà alors effectivement je
ne suis pas allé à szeged
malheureusement je suis allé en hongrie
à budapest avec toi le match bas trop
dans le match j'ai dit paul gaillard
contre non tricot contre alexander
qualif mam lequel budapest dans les
archives de diagonale malheureusement sa
gamme je ne connais pas cependant il ya
eu un championnat du monde jeune ou
laurent frayssinet avaient participé
donc c'est une ville qui a une tradition
échiquéenne certaine avec l'ordination
de beaucoup de tournois à son actif
alors soit le masi c'est pas n'importe
qui je crois c'est le troisième joueur
hongrois et qu'il est même utile promis
un moment donné les sept huit premiers
jours ambroix oui alors effectivement
c'est un très très fort joueur junior il
était extrêmement prometteur maintenant
il n'est moins puisqu'il est plus vieux
mais il est très très fort puisqu'il à
2660 au classement elo on y reviendra
tout à l'heure vous êtes amenés dans les
20 ou 30 premiers mondiaux
elle met dans les trente meilleurs
mondiaux donc c'est un très bon joueur
et etienne bacrot ses notes français
nationale qui donc à 17 ans maintenant
qui revient de sarajevo qui revient de
nombreuses expériences assez difficile
il a joué un match entier repos fils a
joué sarajevo et là ils jouent un match
entre zoltan elle m'a dit alors etienne
bacrot à toute une tradition de match
pour revenir là dessus mais il joue donc
qu'on a vu on avait filmé son match
contre alexander ben alias kiki avait
lieu qui a eu lieu en septembre de temps
en plus souple exactement la date et
mais tous les ans donc il fait un match
dans sa ville
où il avait appris à jouer aux échecs
l'un albert il a joué albert beaucoup de
matchs il avait joué contre donc le
jeune leeuwen aronian l'arménien il a
joué aussi contre cornouaille me sens
encore jeune contre smith l'offre smith
l'ofs
et enfin donc ce match contre al mahdi
je pense qu'on a encore oublié le match
contre eux une mère qui était à albert
et berlin oui c'est un match de double
mais normalement etienne bacrot joue
plutôt chez lui et là c'était un match
en extérieur puisqu'il jouait sur le
territoire de son adversaire c'est à
dire en fait c'est importe c'est
important ce match pour pour sa carrière
parce que c'est on a vu bon qu'il était
encore un peu jeune par rapport à août
up 0 top 10 mondial puisque le tourne à
sarajevo mais il termine dernier bon il
s'est quand même
il s'est quand même battu mais
malheureusement il a il n'a clairement
pas le niveau je crois qu'on peut le
dire pour l'instant
oui progressent il progresse puisque au
dernier classement elo par contre il a
gagné beaucoup de points il se retrouve
maintenant à sailly 66e mondial je crois
donc ça y est il est vraiment rentrer
dans les 100 meilleurs mondiaux donc il
est sur la bonne pente
bon il est vrai que jouer contre
kasparov krainik anand et tout le paquet
c'est très très délicat sa première
immersion dans le grand bain a été un
peu dur il a perdu pied on peut dire
maintenant etienne progresse je joue de
mieux en mieux prendre de l'expérience
et ici il joue contre un joueur à peu
près enfin qui a été très bien calibrée
en tout cas puisque c'est le 30e mondial
c'est entre lui et kasparov si les 60e
donc c'est un joueur plus fort que lui
mais qui peut battre c'est tu peux
raisonnablement espérer battre on n'a
pas mentionné la formule du match on va
le faire tout de suite c'est un match en
partie longue on est si parfait
c'est une formule classique puisque
c'était la même formule peter l'écho
contre kalichman et je crois que si
parti c'est le match c'est le nombre de
partis même quatre chefs qui a fait des
matches à cannes cette année a souvent
fait des matches en six parties c'est le
sait le sait la durée logique oui alors
c'est des matches exhibition quand
c'était les matchs des candidats c'était
plutôt huit partis voire douze partis
voir cette partie là comme c'est des
matches exhibition effectivement on ne
fait pas patienter trop longtemps le
public pourra voir le score final donc
le vainqueur du match est celui qui fait
plus de trois points et mis enfin trois
points et demi au plus est en cas trois
partout il ya donc match nul voila c'est
par contre qu'il compte que tous les
partis comptent toutes les parties donc
même si on a gagné match on continue à
jouer
donc le fil au résultat final importe au
niveau des points elo quel que soit le
résultat
oui effectivement alors peut-être on va
détailler maintenant les parties de ce
match puisqu'on a eu 6 on les
connaissait le match est terminé
donc première partie etienne bacrot à
l'eiblen il a gagné le tirage au sort ou
alors je ne sais pas il a eu les blancs
à la première partie et donc il n'a pas
été très convaincant lors de cette
première partie puisque c'était une
défense là où avec les blancs il n'a
absolument rien fait et ils ont fait une
répétition de coûts très rapide c'est à
dire à peu près vers le 19e coup donc
pas très pas très engageant ce début de
match deuxième partie ils allaient noir
et c'est la torture espagnole qui
commence puisque etienne a récemment
abandonné la défense sicilienne pour
jouer un début plus solide pour jouer le
coup eux 4 5
ce qui est donc plus classique plus
normalement plus solide du résistant à
la carte off un peu voilà la karpov
tienne est en train de se mettre dans
les dents c'est long match kasparov et
karpov c'est à dire des gambie dam des
espagnols toutes ces ouvertures qui sont
très longues et réputé très solide
il est par contre très difficile à tenir
surface des lions parti ça donne
toujours des très longues parties
oui d'où la torture espagnol qui durent
très longtemps beaucoup de coups et en
tout cas quand on n'est pas expérimentée
dans l'ouverture espagnol c'est très
très difficile à tenir et la première
partie contre soltane al mahdi etienne
fait une faute grave dans l'ouverture et
se retrouve donc complètement vie c'est
donc alors par contre à la troisième
dont qui joue avec les blancs il a joué
un cambiste evans refusée par son
adversaire sérieux on joue à quatre ou
cinq cavaliers f3 qu'avait laissé six
pouces et quatre pouces et 5 il en joue
le coup b4 que le gambit evans qui est
pas une ouverture si mauvaise que ça
puisque même fischer l'avait joué on
l'on retrouve dans son livre les 60
meilleures parties et l'abbé almasy
choisi de ne pas prendre le pion mais de
jouer plutôt un coup comme fou b6 avec
donc en gambie est vain de se refuser
alors il me semble que la partie de
fisher c'était une partie simultanée je
crois avec ariane c'était un derby et la
cale partir en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que kasparov a battu à nantes en
jouant le gambit events il n'y a pas si
longtemps il doit y avoir quatre ou cinq
ans il a complètement
enfin la proprement massacrer avec cette
ouverture le fameux sacrifice d'options
b2b 4 que hollande avait accepté et s'en
était finalement mordu les doigts
ici donc en billets verts se refuser et
ensuite almasy fait montre d'une
parfaite
compréhension la position etienne a trop
avancé ses pions sur l' aile gauche de
l'échiquier les dames et finalement a
fini par par se faire mater très
violemment donc match très très mal
engagée à mi match puisque etienne est
menée 2 et demi 1/2
c'est à dire qu'il est dos au mur une
défaite et c'est la fin du match donc ça
c'était très très délicat
quatrième partie c'est zoltan almasy qui
a les blancs nouvelle espagnol etienne
améliore mais ne s'en n'arrive pas à
tirer son épingle du jeu
donc nul très logique est donc ici 3 1
etienne est obligé de gagner les deux
dernières s'il veut s'en sortir c'est à
dire s'il veut égaliser le match
d'égaliser mais tout à fait est là et là
c'est une partie très très beau surfer
ou coincées cinquième partie de zoltan
almasy se fourvoie dans son choix
d'ouverture puisqu'ils ne jouent plus
que 4,5 il décide de s'enflammer il joue
une sicilienne très très surprenante une
sicilienne non classique et une
sicilienne bizarre et finalement se fait
complètement technique et par etienne
c'est à dire une très très belle partie
une très belle finale technique
un peu à l'image de etienne bacrot qui a
perdu contre castard au fond mais c'est
ça la partie ressemble beaucoup à l
inverse serre qui s'est fait dominer par
kasparov comme ça avec un jeu de
va-et-vient on y reviendra dans la
partie et l'a cette fois c'est lui
qu'elle est blanc et c'est lui qui
impose un va-et-vient à l'adversaire
voilà c'est lui qui a pris l'initiative
de faire revers coup droit en revers
coup droit et c'est zoltan almasy qui
courent d'un bout à l'autre de
l'échiquier mais qui n'a eu finalement
plus rattraper la balle suite à une
accélération détiennent donc cinquième
partie etienne l'emportent ça sera la
partie qu'on commencera tout à l'heure
finalement dernière partie d'elle et
noir il est obligé de gagner mais zoltan
almasy avec les blancs est vraiment trop
solide il ne passe pas nul dans cette
dernière partie
il manque bons résultats finalement se
passer par deux miss et une défaite
ouais c'est une défaite mais c'est un
joueur qui est plus fort que lui a
priori ce classement donc fin il est pas
en dessous de son niveau quoi ils
perdent légèrement des points elo mais
ce n'est pas grave effectivement comparé
vu le début du match en tout cas etienne
doit être satisfait de cette deuxième
partie de match puisqu'il marque deux
points sur trois et trois et demi deux
ans et demi ce n'est pas déshonorant
c'est un bon je dirais un bon retour
après la catastrophe de sarajevo
voilà donc en tout cas c'est un bon
entraînement c'est important de faire
des matchs puisqu'on sait que à terme
c'est les matchs qui vont décider d'eux
de l'avenir du joueur coin oui alors ça
c'est une question de point de vue
puisque on va faire une très légère
parenthèse donc dans cet événement de la
semaine
rappelons le championnat du monde de
kasparov qui est fait avec des matches
le champion du monde fis des qui est un
système coupe à élimination directe en
mini matches d'autres partis donc en
tout cas les vrais championnats du monde
c'est à dire qu'il ya deux qui ont donné
lieu aux vrais champions du monde
c'étaient des matches très longs des
matchs 24 parties de voir même plus mon
rallye man champion du monde c'était sur
des mini matchs de deux parties donc
effectivement le système de match en
général la tendance à donner le meilleur
joueur du monde très plus crédible et
plus crédible et puis en tout cas ça
améliore bien le bien de toute façon
bien plus important que le niveau 2 le
niveau de chacun des joueurs
voilà donc je crois qu'on va passer
l'intérêt d'autres analyses de la
semaine avec cette partie donc
finalement détiennent macro qui
reviennent très bien dans le match dans
la cinquième partie l'objet de gagner
pour essayer d'égaliser donc ils
allaient blanc il faut contrôler tamda
de masi la partie de la semaine
voilà donc cette partie avec donc
etienne va croquer les blancs contre
soldats nazis qu'ils allaient noir si on
peut mettre ça peut nous mettre à
l'incrustation en bas à droite de
l'échiquier
on va tout de suite commencer cette
cette partie alors partie donc etienne
bacrot avec les blancs cinquième partie
du match etienne doit l'emporter pour
espérer quelque chose
récemment il s'est mis à jouer le coup
eux 2e 4 à la place de d4 qu'il a
pratiqué toute sa jeunesse entre
guillemets puisque il est encore très
jeune et ici dans cette partie il
choisit de jouer eux quatre contrôles
nazis alors que l machinalement je vous
ai eu cinq donc ici etienne c'était
prenant préparer à affronter aux 4 5 il
avait déjà essayé le gambit events dans
la troisième il avait problème en
préparer quelque chose mais elle masi
est le premier à créer la surprise
puisqu'il joue le coup c'est cette c5
c'est à dire une défense sicilienne
ce qui n'était pas attendu de la part d'
etienne en tout cas vous me connais bien
et qu il tienne qu'on est bien
évidemment puisque c'est quand même
l'ouverture la plus pratiquée au haut
niveau actuellement
oui c'est 4 5 4 500 les deux versions
les plus joués etienne ne se démonte pas
joue le système avec cavaliers f3 c'est
à dire la cécilienne ouverte donc ici
effectivement préparant le coût des deux
des quatre pour instaurer ce fameux duo
pion central très cher aux ouvertures
des chèques cavaliers c6 troisième coup
des deux des quatre puis on prend des
quatre cavaliers prendrait quatre on est
vraiment dans la poudre dans une
position de sicilienne ouverte
les noirs ont repris un petit avantage
de développement puisque c'est à vous de
jouer
et les joueurs ont sorti une pièce
chacun les deux pièces mineurs donc
petit avantage de développement pour les
noirs mais bon pour l'instant on est
vraiment dans l'ouverture on connaît
très bien ses positions là il y en a
beaucoup dans les différents diagonale
zoltan almasy jeu le ku'damm ses sept
coups qu'on a encore jamais vues dans
diagonale parmi les inconnues
wissem coup
curieux enfin disons qu'on s'attend
plutôt un coup de cavaliers le glaude
cavaliers ou un coup de pied hélas
beaucoup d'âme ses sept finales membres
mais de façon c'est une classe naturelle
pour la dame la sicilienne souvent alors
ce n'est pas vraiment une classe
naturelle l'idée de mettre la dame ans
et 7 est toujours de contrôler la case e
pourquoi est-ce qu'on est toujours cette
dame en ces sept là c'est un peu pour
les connaisseurs de cécile n puisque ça
va vous sembler obscures c'est honnête
on n'en avait jamais vu
non mais là d'avancé 7 pour contrôler un
cadeau 5 puisque ce n'est pas une 4
naturelle puisqu'elle va être l'objet
d'une attaque de cavaliers soit ans et 5
soit en b 5
donc c'est une case où la dame va être
amené à à partir en fait en toute
logique
à moins qu'on joue aussi ces assisses
mais en tout cas pour l'instant c'est
une case assez dangereuse l'idée est de
contrôler justement cette case peu 5
pour empêcher les blancs de jouer f 4 5
par la suite donc en fait ici on the
dance et 7 avant même que les blancs
jouer et jouer f4 avant même que les
pièces soient sortis donc c'est vraiment
de la prophylaxie à un niveau
extrêmement élevé extrêmement élevé en
tout cas ça ne crée pas de menace
directe d'un camp des blancs
contrairement au cou cavalière sicile et
noir avaient joué car ils s'y seraient
t'accueille points 4 et donc ça permet
aux bleus de jouer quelque chose qui
s'apparente à ce qu'on appelle les taux
de maroggi oui alors on va voir ce coup
c'est le 5e 5e coup ces deux c4
voilà c'est un coût qui vise bien les
cases blanches et notamment la casse des
l'idée étant que les blancs colonne
ouverte sur la colonne des et qui vont
faire pression au maximum sur cette case
des cinq avec des pièces lourdes et
maintenant les deux pions qui se
contrôle bien la case deux des cinq par
contre en contrepartie ils affaiblissent
un petit peu leurs cases noires voilà
c'est un affaiblissement des cases
noires tout à fait c'est ce qu'on
appelle les taux de marc oxis et les
pions le duo de pions eu quatre essais 4
très classique tout ça c'est très
classique
maintenant ça un revers de médaille
c'est que les blancs perdent encore du
temps c'est à dire que là pour l'instant
ils n'ont sorti qu'une seule pièce alors
les noirs n'ont sorti deux donc ici les
noirs devraient essayer de faire une
réaction très très dynamique très très
concrètes et rapides
sinon ça va être une position longue et
lente hélas ce fameux et thomas roxy
menace de se resserrer et finalement à
long terme de gagner le pion 17 le pion
17 qui va finir par être la cible des
blancs puisque on va tous massés sur la
colonne des comme tu l'as pointe et
voilà tout à fait ici des noirs jouent
kavvadias six ans ses idées très
générales parce que après il faut jouer
les coups coin comme un i phone ou la
partie un jour il y
jouer les coups qu un relief six
cavaliers c3 et jouer donc logique on
défend l'option leucate qui était
attaquée en sortant une pièce mais s'il
ya un problème il y a une pointe
tactique qui évidemment pas échappé au
noir il ya le couple cavalier préemption
aux quatre coups pas très connu mais qui
existe qui prend 0,4
cavalli prend cavaliers très logique et
maintenant la dame c'est 7 vient à eux
cinq attaquants le cavalier ou quatre
avec échec et le cavalier des 4 donc en
fait on fait une fourchette de cavaliers
en récupère le cavani on récupère un
cavalier mais ici il ya un problème
alors je ne sais plus enfin ou en tout
cas c'est du domaine privé
il y a une réputation ici je ne vais pas
vous la donner puisque c'est ce qu'ils
voient là ses secrets dans c'était assez
délicat à trouver ça m'a pris beaucoup
beaucoup de travail
en tout cas ici les blancs les blancs
sont mieux dans cette position je peux
vous l'assurer maintenant effectivement
il faut la jouer il faut la jouer c'est
une position très compliqué ça peut
jouer en partie est très rapide en blitz
on peut jouer en ont peu joué cette
vente mais c'est très très dangereux
puisque les blancs développe une
initiative vraiment énorme
les noirs essaie tant bien que mal de
tenir mais finalement n'y arrive pas
enfin arrive dans un premier temps à ne
rien perdre
maëlys est vide et blanc continue en
fait au delà au delà de ce qu'on
pourrait attendre
et donc ce sacrifice d'options n'en est
finalement pas un puisque c'est bon pour
les blancs donc saultain almasy ne
jouent pas ne prend pas le 15/04 rend
pas ce risque mais joue plutôt un coût
plus tranquille je le 6 à l'idée de
sortir leur faut il suit l'idée c'est de
ses deux mètres le fou probablement sur
la case b4 qui tout le cavalier c3 et
qui du coup fait pression sur le pion à
quatre essais on voit c'est là qu'on
voit que les cases noires soient
affaiblies en fait c'est là qu'on voit
que les cases noires sont affaiblis
c'est là aussi qu'on voit que les blancs
ou un petit problème de développement
puisqu'ils n'ont pas encore blindé leur
centre on voit que le cahier des cats et
emprise qui empêche de jouer donc fou
des trois coups qu'on aurait envie de
jouer donc il ya quelques problèmes dans
la position blanche mais en tout cas si
étienne arrive à tenir ici eh bien ça
sera les taux de maroci finalement
puisque les noirs donc pour l'instant
pas
fait preuve d'une agressivité suffisante
pour déstabiliser le centre des blancs
peu s'il faut deux photos logique très
calme très calme etienne cavale et prend
cavaliers alors il prend quand est-ce
que c'est pas une position en une
décision un peu prématuré sa vision
assez surprenante
l'idée de mettre le fou en c5 c'est ce
qu'on va voir en fait ici on reviendra
peut-être après sur cette position mais
après dame prend des quatre on joue
maintenant fous ces cinq avec gagne
autant sur la dame quand même bien de
temps sur la dame c'est à dire qu'on a
développé le fou on vient de le sortir
et on attaque la dame blanche sur la
caisse des cartels va donc être obligé
de partir la dame étant une pièce assez
importante on peut pas la laisser en
danger en se grattant développement mais
mais l'on peut se poser la question en
faire a priori le coup le plus souvent
joué c'est plutôt fourbe les quatre
foulées 4 au lieu de calais prend des
caveaux les deux cas les preuves des
quatre et qui permet de faire pression
sur le pion aux quatre centrales qui
obtiennent des parties intéressantes
mais il me semble qu'après foulée katia
petit rock avec un sacrifice d'options
est extrêmement dangereux pour les noirs
les statistiques blanche étant
clairement leur faveur
donc ici zoltan allemagne et trop obligé
de trouver quelque chose en tout cas il
a évidemment préparé cette position il
la connaît c'est il ya aucun doute là
dessus
donc il a son idée en tout cas il gagne
un temps sur la dame en attendant après
dam des trois joué par etienne bacrot
ici zoltan almasy joue petit rock
donc en fait il se met dans une logique
qui n'est qui est contraire au sens de
la position on peut dire puisque en fait
il là il est en train de tout faire pour
ce faire vis et ouais pour ce faire
baisser puisque il ne joue pas assez va
réussir la joue pas assez dynamique et
il va finir par y arriver
etienne joue maintenant la etienne joue
très bien ici etienne joue très très
bien
il a vraiment fait un bon concept
normalement on aurait pu s'attendre à
petit rock mais il préfère donc etienne
bacrot préfère jouer 10 fou g5 menacé
c'est à dire ils menacent maintenant de
prendre le khalife 6 en cassant la
structure de pions des noirs alors c'est
une menace qui ne va pas forcément être
effectués tout de suite mais c'est dans
l'air c'est dans le vent voilà ça peut
revenir à tout moment et il faut que les
noirs fille fasse attention face aux
tensions aux conséquences en tout cas
alors pourquoi c'est bien joué c'est
parce que ça profite du fait que le fou
de zoltan almaty soit en c5 et pas sur
le gaz naturel qui était donc la case
eaux cette
cette case là donc ici fou g5 met de la
pression on n'est pas pressé de roke
mais simplement de la pression sur ce 4e
6e ya une pointe au coup d'après c'est
qu'après b6 joué par zoltan almasy qui
veut très logiquement mettre son fou sur
la grande diagonale etienne joue
maintenant tour d un et on peut supposer
que sur flu bessette le coup naturel et
bien on va le regarder d'ailleurs sont
fourbes et cette soif ou 17 ans
l'impression que ça gagne un pur voilà
c'est fou point f6 faut point cavaliers
en élimine deux défenseurs
je crois que le défenseur est éliminé
hop le pilote 17 n'est plus protégé et
la dame peut prendre le pion 17 donc ici
un champ plus pour etienne qui avait
donc en fait en jouant le coup ou g5
anticiper ce qui allait faire les noirs
c'est à dire b6 fauvez set pour réagir à
ça justement par le coup tour d un après
pesticides joue tour d un évitant fou
bessette
pour l'instant donc ça c'est une
subtilité mais qui a son importance
évidemment puisque à ce niveau là à ce
niveau de jeu on ne peut rien laisser
passer
toute faute et immédiatement exploité
dans la zone tama j'ai choisi le coup
internati x 6 alors qu'il n'a pas l'air
d'en empêcher la menace de prendre
finalement le bleu le pian 17 n'a pas
l'air d'en pêcher et menaces mais quand
même puisque après donc maintenant le
couffo point m6 sa part la menace on
veut dire d'une façon indirecte vous
prendre six pions prend m6 très logique
donc d'un prend 17
donc ça a l'air de gagner le pion
salaire de gagner pions on échange les
dames la tour vient reprendre et là on
analyse était qu'il y avait le couffo b4
mais alors je ne suis pas tout à fait
sûr c'est à vérifier mais après faut
bekkat il semblerait qu'on menace de
doubler les pions avec français 3 et
qu'ensuite on va récupérer psion c4
simplement jouant tour f 8 ans et 8 très
simplement
donc ici en fait on exploite le fait que
le fou son assise pour aller ramasser le
pion en c4 c'est une idée en tout cas
c'est peut-être ça c'est peut-être autre
chose c'est s'aider très bon joueur on
peut vraiment expliqué mme bessette on
aurait permis ça parce que le fou en a
600 l'impression que vous qui ont pu
ainsi 4 quand même protégé pour le fou
de bon en fait mais c'est vrai que
positionnelle mance et des pions de
doubler sur une colonne verte donc on
peut supposer que c'est des pions faible
oui c'est dire que le fond bessette et
neutralisé par le coin f2 f3 mais c'est
ce qui va se passer dans la partie donc
on va voir comment ça se passe après
fois ci donc etienne décide de ne pas
jouer pour le ciss maintenant
il peut également très bien joué petit
rock dans cette position c'est un coût
possible mais il joue plus subtil que ça
il veut vraiment faire quelque chose
contre ce pion 17 il veut s'en occuper
rapidement donc ici le jour où j'ai cinq
ans lâche 4 idées probablement un retour
sur cette caste g3 puis un blocage sur
la case des six ans fait et yade veut
bloquer la position noir complètement
ici il veut étouffer zoltan al-majid ça
c'est une possibilité
fu h quatre en tout cas c'est un coup
intéressant petit rock était jouable
également bon chacun ses choix
faux h 4 et la foulée 4 funka finalement
contraire contraire aux règles oui au
genou font la même caisse envers deux
fois la même pièce bon par contre il
coule cavaliers et il menace peut-être
fou prendre cavaliers puisque la dame ne
pourrait pas reprendre cause du pion au
cadran prise et on sera obligé du père
du pillon b en doublant les pions sur la
colonne c'est ce qui sort et pénible
puisque on voit que le pion 6-4 serait
perdu quasiment immédiatement derrière
oui si c'est une menace positionnelle la
menace est fou prend cavaliers
effectivement bon c'est intolérable de
jouer et puis on prend fusée de
reprendre avec le pion à cause de ses
pions doublé donc il faut trouver une
solution et maintenant que le fouet
partie de la caste c5 etienne fait ce
qu'on appelle le mouvement de la
pendulette c'est à dire qu'il repart
pour mieux revenir
il joue maintenant fou prend cavani
décider si demain il se décide donc tu
comprends qu'avec lui on prend fut la
réponse trop logique et maintenant ils
gagnent du temps puisqu'il joue le coup
à deux à trois voilà il ne joue pas non
pas d'en prendre 17 puisqu'on a vu que
d'en prendre 17 serait sûrement une
faute à cause de la du diplôme ou blé
noir pour une grosse pression sur les
pions c'est ici c'est d'apprendre et 7
ans n'ayant perdu un temps en plus en
plus on aurait perdu un temps par
rapport à la variante de tout à l'heure
donc il a il avait une autre variante
qui lui permet de garder la souplesse de
sa structure de pions parce que
maintenant le petit 1 4 n'est plus
attaquer donc le foot attaqué s'il prend
le cavalier ont pour reprendre de la
dame et on se retrouve et des fous de
même couleur avec une petite peut-être
pression blanche sur le plan des moyens
de payer le fou ne peut plus maintenant
se stabiliser sur la casse et 5
puisqu'il aura du b2b 4 dans l'air donc
ce fou en b4 un avenir assez incertain
dans cette position saultain almasy
décide donc
de jouer faux prend cavaliers c'est
quasiment obligé l'incidence et les
pions de 17 qui était perdu
sinon ils furent 17 et perdu oui tout à
fait donc c'était en fait complètement
forcé ou effectivement fou prend
cavaliers c'est pas un coup qu'on a
envie de jouer mais ici ce que zoltan
almasy a dû se dire dans cette position
bon effectivement on est en finale enfin
en tout cas y'a plus de pièces mineur il
y a plus trop de perspectives d' attaque
dans cette position donc je vois pas
pourquoi je ferais pas nul très
facilement dans cette finale il va me
suffire de tenir l'option 17 le pion f6
je vais ramener le roi au centre et puis
on va faire nul e mail à etienne bacrot
n'est pas d'accord donc il prend le fou
déjà un menace d'un programme premier
fils a déjà tout de suite d'un
profession f6 effectivement même si le
pion c4 est en prise en retour une dame
en bref si ça fait très très peur ça
fait extrêmement peur c'est même
insupportable
puisque c'est trop proche trop proche du
roi donc il faut pas tolérer ça d'un
mètre 4 donc tu la dame vient f4 la dame
rose noir donc la protège bien le pion
m6 programme action contre attaqué en 24
donc un coup à double effet il faut pas
laisser passer ça et là etienne fait un
choix ça dans cette position il a le
choix de défendre son plus haut car il
peut jouer f2 f3 mais il ne le fait pas
il préfère dans cette position à les
échanger les dames
ils recherchent les changes avec 16
dames j'ai trois échecs donc d'un
programme et forcé et maintenant on
reprend du pillon et ici c'est peut-être
lors d'un petit bilan ça c'est alors
c'est intéressant ils financent par ok
il a décidé de laisser son roi au centre
finalement il va laisser son rôle
central etienne voilà le roi centre en
finale est mieux placé pourquoi parce
qu'il est plus près du centre et qu'il a
plus aucune chance en principe au final
de se faire attaquer de se faire mater
puisqu'elle plus les dames
donc ça c'est important autre élément la
tour en h1 est très bien placé
maintenant puisque elle va attaquer le
curage set elle va menacer de monter sur
les cases et pouvoir s'activer sur cette
5e traverse et les blancs en tout genre
de pression et bien sûr le pion de 17
pression sur lyon 17 également c'est
vrai n'a l'intention d'approuver la
menace des blancs tout simplement de
tout reprendre
lyon 17 août en provenance de sète est
une menace sérieuse donc ici il ne faut
pas tolérer ça bon maintenant ce qu'on
peut voir c'est il faut toujours se
demander quel est le bon fou qu'elle est
le mauvais fond alors stéphane
normalement qu'est ce qu'on lit sur les
bons et les mauvais
moi j'ai l'impression que le football
n'est pas bon parce qu'il tape sur ses
propres pions voilà on a l'impression
que le football n'est pas bon et en fait
c'est faux en fait c'est le fou noir qui
est pas bien ça c'est assez curieux ça
c'est intéressant
alors effectivement le fond blanc et sur
la même couleur que ses pions on a
l'impression qu'il tape pas sur les
plans adverses mais sur les siens donc
il est un peu bouchés par ses propres
pions les bouchers alors que le fou
adverse a l'air de pouvoir créer des
menaces sur les pions blancs tout à fait
mais en fait ces menaces sont totalement
fictive puisqu'elle son pari très
simplement
alors là on va enlever quelques flèches
parce qu'il commence à y en avoir trop
donc enlevons tout ça hop tranquillement
tout ça est amené à disparaître
voilà qu'est ce qui se passe avec ce fou
à 6 voilà la question pourquoi ce qui
serait pas bon et bien simplement parce
qu'on assiste déjà il est devant un pion
il est devant le pion à 7 qui ne peut
pas avancer
voilà sa salle il est mal placé l'un
peuvent toujours si cris sur bessette
parlent à leurs maîtres en b 7 mai la
etienne bacrot ce qu'on est en train de
jouer f2 à f3
donc en fait le fou bessède va être
complètement muselé mais sans prendre un
fusil
le fougueux aussi mais là qu'est ce qui
va faire la différence c'est le fou
qu'on attaque ou qu'on n'attaque pas 5e
fois en dix-sept n'est pas défendu il
est en l'air il est en prise si une tour
arrive elle attaque le fou alors que le
fond blanc lui est défendu par son roi
donc pas de problème le roi peut monter
sur les cases noires ça c'est très très
important finale de fou c'est que le roi
en longtemps à côté de ses pions en
contrôler les cases de reposer à celle
de son fou ipo contre lesquelles se pose
est celle de son fouet en plus il n'est
pas sur la couleur du fou et demi donc
ça c'est très important c'est à dire
qu'ici après trois ans on va mettre le
roi henri iii
effectivement le fougueux et pas très
bon mais l'autre fou et emprises donc le
taux est encore plus mauvais c'est ça
qu'il faut voir
donc ici etienne à une meilleure
structure puisqu'il suffit de compter
les groupes d'options de groupe pour les
blancs d'oeufs groupe point lecture en
a3 b2 et c 4 qui peuvent tous s'auto
protéger les pieux 4 f2 g2 et g3 qui
peuvent tous se protour protéger contre
trois pions trois groupes pour les noirs
à 7 et b6 suivi d'un suite de 17,6 f67
scène et achète tout seul ça fait trois
groupes donc trois motifs d'attac voilà
donc meilleure structure d'options pour
etienne bacrot des pièces plus dynamique
les deux tours sont déjà sur les bonnes
cases et 3 un petit avantage on va dire
philosophique puisque son fou est un peu
mieux que le fou et demi donc ici trois
avantages pour etienne mais maintenant
il faut transformer en mai
c'est très dur parce que là c'est
vraiment un avantage minime en fait
c'est bon c'est une voix un bon c'est
des avantages qu on peut citer mais
c'est vrai qu'en réalité ils sont quand
même très très très très léger d'autant
plus que nous n'aurons pas beaucoup de
faiblesses
le pion 17 va à la longue a défendu très
solidement donc on se demande comment
les blancs vous pouvoir transformer ça
et là intervient la technique
tous rêvent d vite jouée par zoltan
almasy etien protège le pion 17 31
actions 17 etienne prend son temps joue
le coup b2 b3 pour l'instant il n'y a
pas de souci à se faire les noirs ne
peuvent pas se libérer ni par 17 des 5
qui sera en prise ni par b 6 baies 5 qui
sera en prison qui seraient aux prises
aussi donc pour l'instant pas de
problème les noirs sont muselés tour ses
huit toujours pas de menace tour h5n1
celades c'est là qu'on se rappelle de la
partie de kasparov cela fait partie de
la partie kasparov bacrot un test par of
avait donc à sarajevo en avait commenté
dans des flash kasparov avait avait un
peu pendule est entre guillemets etienne
à droite et à gauche
grâce à ces tours de la même façon qu'on
le voit qu'au niveau là alors si vous
voulez revoir cette partie je vous
invite à voir le diagonal du 19 mai dans
les archives
vous allez sur ce diagonale du 19 mai
c'est une émission spéciale sur sarajevo
avec la partie kasparov bacrot très bien
commenté
et là vous verrez un peu une autre
finale dans ce style da très technique
avec les tours qui monte qui se baladent
les fameuses tours niveau l'oni donc
tourage 5-fu bessette non policier
d'attac le point 4 donc il faut faire
attention
évidemment à ce pion attaque le piano k
o en bas de la tour h 56 contrôle bien
la casse des 5 1 secondes et 5 est de
moins en moins possible pour l'épauler
noir très important cette tour contrôle
des cinq est également b5
donc en fait contrôler les leviers de
pions des noirs est aussi m5 est aussi
m5 tous les leviers de tueur noirs sont
contrôlées par ce coup tous âges 5 qui
est donc un coup superbe vin f3 pas de
problème pour etienne la prochaine étape
c'est de monter le roi ça va être ça
puisqu'on aura du mal à améliorer ce fou
en attendant donc pour l'instant les
noirs sont toujours sous pression avec
l'option 17 à rire est un peu le roi
noir lui peut pas venir vers le centre
puisqu'il doit protéger le pion h7
c'est le boat is des chaînes de pions on
voit que ce pion tout seul avait
finalement mais faut qu'une pièce le
défendre et c'est le roi par exemple ici
on peut prévoir web2com menace pour les
blancs suivi deux tours des engins
qui vient ne plus racheter à petit gain
de recettes donc les noirs sont vraiment
sous pression oui si roy g7 donc angers
7 b permettra de jouer tourache 8 en cas
de la manoeuvre que tu as cité si on
double le tout fera qu une tâche qui
permettra donc toi je suis trop f2 donc
là on active le roi c'est logique en
fait quand y'a pas grand chose à faire
il faut aussi d'améliorer la position de
ces pièces avant d'engager une action
oui le fameux principe quand vous ne
savez plus quoi faire chercher la pièce
qui ne travaillent pas et améliorer là
tout simplement ici c'est le roi qui
travaillent de moins il faut donc
l'améliorer h6 on peut encore jouer war
3 mais ici etienne joue un coup assez
subtil assez intéressant ils jouent la
coupe des 3 b car dès lors du dialogue
sont kasparov
il a compris que pour gagner il fallait
avoir deux motifs d'attac - pour pouvoir
balader l'adversaire d'un motif à
l'autre donc là il ya un motif d'
attaquer le plus rage si ce qui peut
mettre qui peut être mis sous pression
grâce à lui ou deux tours et maintenant
il faut qu'ils crème un autre motif d'
attaques de l'autre côté et pour ça il a
une majorité mobile + plus importante
que celle des noirs
oui on peut aussi dire que le pion de 17
peut être faible en fait cédé 2 me
faiblesse ce pion à chistian 17
donc il en faut un petit peu plus et
c'est ce qui va essayer de faire en fait
il essayait d'ouvrir une colonne de
l'autre télé chic et ça c'est très bien
joué c'est comme l'avait joué kasparov
c'est exactement ça donc et il a obtenu
le son peut dire voilà c'est d'ailleurs
cette partie a été ressentie comme une
leçon
oui c'était vraiment la leçon pas de
piano mais en tout cas la leçon
d'allers-retours sais pas comment on
pourrait l'appeler des six alors des si
cela est ce que ça c'est un coup capable
de faire grand chose
oui mais il n'y a pas grand-chose à
faire puisque maintenant en fait le
couple et noir avaient envie de jouer
c'était fou c6 et pas de problème pour
défendre l'option c'est le pont 17
maintenant faut c'est 600 calories 5b
quatre baies 5 pouces le fou ailleurs
les quatre dessins qui est au programme
donc des 6 à 4 étienne fonce donc il
veut vraiment se créer un motif de
percussion de l'autre côté vous
ouvrir une autre colonne on peut
vraiment le dire il va jouer à 5 mettre
la pression et au bon moment prendre en
b6 et envahir la colonne à voilà le plan
des blancs fois six attaques le pion c4
pas de problème b 5 mes5 s'aliène
repousse le fou repousse le four est le
fou pas en baisse est maintenant un
petit coup à droite autour des achats
donc la menace tout reprend h6 il faut
absolument protéger le plus rage 6 une
deuxième fois
voilà deux tours de tours à l'attack ce
qu'on allait prêter tout à leur attaque
l'option entourage suite défense est
maintenant un gros coup à gauche voilà
au passage donc là c'est vraiment du
ping pong
voilà c'est ça c'est c'est boris becker
en pleine action 26 à 5
la menace je pense qu'on peut envisager
que ce soit le coût à 5 à 6 peut-être
qu'ils mettraient le fourbe et sept sur
la case à 8 de laquelle il ne
ressortirait jamais oui ça peut être
aussi apprendre b6 et toura on ne fait
pas trop on sait pas trop mais en tout
cas à six mois je trouve je trouve ça
assez séduisant comme que comme
perspective on en a vite il sera pas
moins bien placé qu'en b siècle facile
puisqu'il pourra plus jamais aller on
s'est vite il n'est parce qu'il n'ya pas
de case g9 b9
ouais donc tout simplement donc ici à 5
menace probablement à 6 à mon avis si on
prend à 5x et pour s'appeler noir
prennent mais parfois ça crée une
faiblesse c'est le pion à 7
voilà maintenant alors c'est encore pire
puisque là qu'est ce qu'on voit c'est
que les blancs alors rien il quelque
chose qui est très très important finale
lothion c'est le sens de la chaîne de
pions en finale il faut que les pions
aille vers les ailes pourquoi parce
qu'on les défende depuis le centre tir
que le roi les défends depuis le centre
et les pions sont dangereux jusque dans
les coins et ça c'est très très
important ici les blancs ont rappliqué
ça à merveille maintenant ils jouent
tour à 1 on voit que pour défendre
l'option b 5
en fait la base il suffit de défendre le
fou aux deux donc défendre le fougueux à
la base c'est très simple on le défend
avec le roi donc toutes les pièces
blanches se tiennent mutuellement
alors que les noirs bon maintenant leur
seuil est un pur faible en a cinq
un pion faible en a cette fois joué le
coup peut-être à 7 à 6 pour se
débarrasser de cette faiblesse la wii il
te jouer à 7 à 6 mais bon il ya
simplement tour points à 5
et après tu comprends b5 ses premiers
singles et blanc aura un pion passer ses
propres actions passées et le fourbe et
7 qui n'est toujours pas stable ce qu'on
a mentionné début c'est à dire que quand
la colonne va s'ouvrir le fait que ce
fou bessette là
le fou noir ne puisse pas être défendue
par des pions ou par son conjoint ou par
son roi c'est très très grave puisque
quand on attaque il ne sait plus où
aller
donc ici gros problème pour les noirs
panique de zoltan almasy ne sait plus
quoi faire il est en train de remarquer
que cette position par envoyer un igloo
en grand voilà donc les décident boom de
taper au centre y lâche la faire ouais
en fait ils lâchent un peu la faire il
joue le coup des six des cinq qui n'est
quand même pas un coup qu'on a vraiment
envie de jouer puisque il semblerait que
ça perdre un pion alors effectivement
peut-être laissé un on voit on voit vite
aussi que si les blancs prennent en d5
deux fois les noirs vont pouvoir faire
pression sur le plan des 5 oui ils vont
probablement le récupérer après avec des
perspectives de faire nul donc ici
etienne bacrot maintenant mais sont le
va-tout sur le fou bessette pas protéger
ce qu'yves essayé de l'attaquer pour le
déstabiliser bien donc il ne se
préoccupe pas de ce pion des cinq
puisque si le prends ça va être repris
par le fou noir et ça on n'a pas envie
on n'a pas envie de ce fou arrive à
respirer c'est ça tout l'enjeu de cette
partie
donc tout reprend 1,5 extrêmement
logique menace tout repos à cette
attaque loubès est donc menaces quand
même assez assez importante à ces
critiques torah 5 et ici je n'y a je
crois qu'il ya plus vraiment de solution
plus vraiment de solution pour les noirs
si on prend en 8e retour à 8
mais là ça va le prendre des cinq sri
perdre le sens parce que si les tournois
redeviennent passive c'est terminé pour
réattaquer sur des 5
donc il faut qu'il faut trouver une
autre solution le puits en cet été en
prie donc il faut qu'ils continuent leur
contre attaque finalement ils n'ont pas
vraiment le choix
là on voit les les tours détiennent
superbe et une en reste un créneau h5
vraiment un peu comme kasparov qui avait
mis des tours g5 et à 5
c'est vraiment il ya une similitude
entre ces deux partis qui fait donc la
participation détiennent à sarajevo
n'est pas un échec total
oui mais au moins ça lui aura permis de
gagner cette partie saluera prône ont
permis à cette partie des princes et
captant l'attention parce qu'on
al'impression alors tout de suite
tiennent à calculer tout ça évidemment
mais là donc etienne a bien réussi à
mettre la pression sur le camp adverse
du côté droit et du côté gauche mais par
contre les noirs maintenant on ce qu'on
appelle un client passer tout de suite
un pion qui peut la dame se tue en c4
qui peut qui peut s'avérer dangereux oui
qui s'avère déjà extrêmement dangereux
puisqu'il à trois casses de promotion
soutenue par une tour oui très important
aussi
la tour est derrière donc ici le pion
vraiment fait office d'épouvantail fait
peur il fait très peur mais etienne a
tout vu et ne panique donc pas jouer le
couteau rond à 7 donc attaque le fou
attaque fou 17 tout à fait le fou alors
évidemment on n'a pas envie de partir
sur les cases amitié une case
catastrophique puisque après on peut
envisager énormément de possibilités
pour etienne haumont notamment ramené
sept tours quand même sept tours h 5 en
juin puis en c1 pour bloquer le pion et
puis finalement et c'est leur déception
b6 b71 peut-être donc ici problème pour
la magie ils jouent ces 3
c'est ce qu'on peut appeler un coup
intermédiaire puisqu'on s'aperçoit
rapidement que six tours pamfou on peut
le voir totalement très et aux profs ou
tout simplement les noirs jouent ces
deux et le pion ne peut plus être arrêté
il faut jouer tour h&m faut donner une
pour vous donner une tour pour arrêter
les pions c'est à dire se retrouve avec
une qualité de monde qui sera peut-être
défendable mais effectivement c'est pas
c'est pas une option c'est pas une
option dans cette position donc etienne
très logiquement dans cette position
après ces trois bouts qui va passer pour
un coût intermédiaire jeu tour h1 voilà
il ne sera surtout pas le fou évidemment
ça serait une grosse faute mais il
protège bien la casse et en cas de ces
deux mélanges ou tour s'il bloque le
pion tour ces voix là et comme made in
the beach une fois qu'on a bloqué
l'ennemi il faut l'attaquer
donc en fait dans un premier temps ils
essaient de bloquer le pion et ensuite
le ramasser puisque on voit que les
pièces noires sont complètement
impuissante à aider les pions le fou
bessette est muselée complètement le roi
est hors jeu
donc ici le roi blanc et production le
fond blanc aussi donc pas de problème
sauf pioncer 3 va passer à la casserole
tourache un tour c'est cette course et 7
protège le fou bessette et en même temps
continuer à protéger option c3 par
contre une petite surcharge faut
contrôler les deux il ya une surcharge
est effectivement de surcharger la
etienne france entend placer une
c'est un joli concert joli coup
normalement ici un joueur débutant a
tendance à tout de suite vouloir
attaquer de plus ont tout de suite
vouloir aller le prendre au plus vite
étienne très tranquillement je crois en
eux trois facile il met le roi dans le
carré du pion bon c'est pas forcément
important puisqu'on n'est pas en finale
deux pions il ya d'autres pièces qui
peuvent l'arrêter mais il se rapproche
du pion pour finalement aller le manger
tout cru ces deux tours c'est un ces
deux tours c'est là donc leur bloc notes
bloquent le pion la lanque leurs menaces
probablement roi des deux qui a continué
à attaquer le pion il serait pas
tellement défendable ce serait difficile
après une fois le roi des deux fous
détroit le pion serait éternue tout à
fait donc menacés par des deux qui gagne
l'option tour des huit pour empêcher roi
des deux roues à f2 donc là etienne
n'est pas pressé bon moment mais il a
perdu un temps on ya perdu un temps mais
c'est pas grave
est-ce que c'est grave d'avoir perdu en
attendant cette position basse
apparaissait toujours embêtant quand
même 40 ans c'est embêtant et c'est
effectivement c'est embêtant
bon bah peut-être toxines tout de suite
peut-être peut-être que tout ça aurait
été mieux que roy et trois en tout cas
wyniwyg d'ailleurs c'est vrai que vu
comme ça vu d'une façon historique
historique c'est à dire qu'on jouera
trois et deux coups après 11 jours à f2
ça a pas l'air bon bon maintenant
revenir un jour à fuiter dire mais si tu
veux jouer 3 je rejoue tourner vite et
tu te situes féroé 2 mais ça va être nul
c'est pas tout à fait comme ça qu'il
faut le voir puisqu'il découvre
intermédiaire entre temps il ya eu ces
deux tours simples ont été joués celle
ci l'avait pas jouer 3 3 qu'est ce qui
dit que olten almasy aura joué ces deux
émissions
rien donc on ne peut pas savoir c'est
comme des subtilités enfin on peut les
analyser l'état qu'il a quand même joué
ses deux enfants voilà il arrive à
provoquer c'est le tour des deux donc là
par contre ce roi de trois tours de 8
c'est dire que si le roi revient revient
bien entendu la tour blanche revient
aussi en attendant avoir vraiment
revient en élite
voilà ça c'est assez clair donc ici
etienne mais le roi aux attaques à tour
la tour revient alors maintenant sa
tournée la tour 17 qui vient protéger la
tour d2 mais la cia
da problème en une menace c'est tout
reprend fou de cette tour profond
bessette oui oui oui c'est possible
enfin ça ne marche pas quand même vous
voyez voyage en échec sur la case d un
probablement non pour prouver cette
c'est possible
non ici aurait simplement tourteron faut
deux échecs voilà pour les voilà tous
reprendre tout prend tôt et après
tourcoing c'est de tout reprendre et 5
c'est une partie nulle
c'est une partie complètement nul une
finale deux tours 4 contre 4 sur la même
elle celle là on parle d'épicés dans
l'air c'est dans l'air fallait faire
attention à ça quoi voilà tout à fait
donc ici
méfiance tout reprend bessette est
possible mais n'est pas bon on amène
n'amène à rien étienne préfère jouer le
coutour à deux donc l'avion ces deux oui
on remarque encore que ce fou 17 n'est
plus dans le truc donc là c'est
exactement ce qu'on disait c'est que les
blancs jouent avec deux pièces de plus
dans cette zone de l'échiquier ils ont
droit et vous en plus d'enfants et
franck trouve donc ils vont finir par
ramasser espions c'est nous et ensuite
ça sera un gain assez simple alors là
est ce que les noirs pourraient pas
jouer le coup maintenant
non ils ne peuvent pas à la protégée de
sources et de ses possibles pour ces 7
est pas possible puisque la tour d2
serait emprise donc là ça y est c'était
assez terminé quoi c'est terminé on va
perdre le pion ces deux en tout cas
voilà maintenant effectivement une fois
qu'on a perdu son fiancé 2 je crois que
c'est désespéré toujours à cause de ce
même problème
le fou bessette qui ne peut pas être
soutenus par un pion ouais existe
toujours c'est vrai que là on voit qu'il
est mauvais parce qu'il fait rien se
fout là il fit rien du tout il bute sur
le point 4 il sert à rien alors que le
fouet deux protège très bien le pion
avancé des blancs le film tube i think
qui est lui-même d'ailleurs on était
noir pour le foie de faire simple
contrôle très bien à cannes blanches
tout à fait tout à fait un été noir
je suis tout à fait d'accord 35 tours à
deux donc f5
alors on essayait de faire revivre le
fou par un essai de faire vivre le foot
17 malheureusement après le pion aux
quatre c'est le pion f3 qui restent qui
bloque le fou oui tout à fait alors
évidemment ici etienne ne se laisse pas
prendre son pion eu quatre pros f5
d'abord puis on prend et maintenant
c'est l'heure du ramassage d'options
tout reprend ces deux noms gagnant
gagnant gagnant et surtout on a un pur
b5 tout seul pas c'est maintenant qu'ils
menacent d'aller faire d'âme et avec au
final bellingham facilement gaine
technique classique alors oui qu'est-ce
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ici depuis la
première position on a fait un bilan où
les noirs avaient donc
plusieurs faiblesses un fou moins bon et
un petit désavantage de développement
ici qu'est ce qu'on voit il ya un pion
de moins il ya plus le désavantage de
développement mais par contre le roi
blanc est encore meilleur le fou blanc
est encore meilleur et il ya ce pion
passé c'est à dire que là il ya vraiment
tout pour que ce soit un gain blanc
facile un gain blanc assez facile et je
pense qu'à partir du moment où il ya eu
cette position là aucun des deux
adversaires n'avaient plus de doute ils
ont continué à jouer par inertie
mais là on sait très bien que etienne
bacrot va gagner cette partie pour
penser de tout repenser deux tours des
six donc pourquoi pas pour mettre la
tour en b 6 enfin il n'y a plus on peut
plus vraiment proposer des idées de
défense puisque ça n'a plus aucun sens
c'est gagnant pour les blancs
pour ces 3 c'est un conte pour gagner
ils veulent atteindre le 40e coup en
fait pour vous et je pense que l'idée
peut-être de jouer tour des 3 celui de
roi des 2 aussi enfin en tout cas amener
le roi vers l'option ici les coûts non
plus une grosse importance on peut on
peut franchement dire ça fout des 5 fu
c4 propose d'échanger des fous la finale
deux tours est gagnante oui alors là on
voit de toutes les transformations mène
à un gain blanc alors là pour conserver
cette technique est évidemment mais à ce
niveau là avec le pion passé b5 on gagne
facilement mais à tour derrière le pion
la tournant est obligé de protéger c'est
le roi qui vient embêter la tour noire
après oui oui alors ça c'est
effectivement il faut consulter les
modules de finale de la leçon les
modules sur les finales de tours qui ne
sont pas encore diffusée mais qui vont
l'être
ici c'est une finale deux tours gagnante
de façon triviale quand la tour est
derrière le pion c'est à dire quand la
tour des fonctions est derrière lui
c'est très facile à gagner tour aux six
échecs roi des deux et là on s'aperçoit
que tout rossi s'était prenons un coût
pourrait mettre enfin pour pour pouvoir
abandonner de façon décente mais c'est à
dire qu'il voulait vraiment abandonner
le combat dans cette pression puisque
maintenant les fous sont forcément
échangés oui parce que le fond noir sont
bouchés la tour qui perdu voilà le 20
mars et chloé tout seul donc on va
échanger les fous ici c'est une
certitude et donc la finale au tour est
inévitable et le requin blanc est donc
forcé voilà l'idée c'est qu'on met
simplement la tour blanche derrière le
pion aux menaces de plus espions la tour
noire est obligé de venir bloquer et
c'est le roi maintenant qui s'avance qui
attaquent la tour qui est obligé de
partir et on pousse encore ce pion
jusqu'à dames et on échange le pion
contre la toux ou selon l'adage de
niveau beach la tour et le
mauvais des bloqueurs voilà donc la tour
ne peut pas vraiment bloqué et le roi
noir ne pourra pas venir protéger parce
que d'abord il est très loin et ensuite
s'il vient c'est tous les pions noirs
qui vont être perdus parce que la tour
blanche va faire une razzia
c'est trop bon je fais la nasa tous ses
pions sont très faibles ils peuvent pas
se défendre mutuellement
donc ici guinde etienne bacrot dans une
partie très technique et donc
effectivement sa partie contre kas
peroff ne lui a pas été inutile ici
voilà donc il n'aura pas perdu pour rien
donc bien tout cas c'est beau de voir
qu'il a il a pris on a vraiment le
sentiment qu'il a pris une leçon de
kasparov et que ça lui a servi dans
cette partie voilà voilà c'est
exactement ça c'était un investissement
c'est un investissement voilà exactement
ouais c'est de très belles parties de
donc d' etienne bacrot donc finalement
montre qui est un grand champion
puisqu'il menait 2-0 ils arrivent à
remonter dans le score même s'il arrive
pas à égaliser le match je fais quand
même un match tout à fait correcte et on
va passer maintenant je crois à notre
parti les nouvelles de la semaine les
news les news en fait
il
voilà les news de la semaine donc avec
d'abord b le nouveau classement mondial
c'est toujours pareil un soir de janvier
sont en juillet le classement mondial
paraît ça y est il est là et on attend
toujours avec impatience parce que c'est
là où on voit que le soit dans le top
français qui nous intéresse aussi où le
top mondial dont on voit les nouveaux
les nouveaux joueurs qui font parler de
quoi oui oui tout à fait donc ici on va
commenter ce classement ce classement
mondial en premier peut-être avec en
première position une énorme surprise et
une surprise et oui puisque depuis
quinze ans est toujours le même c'est
garry kasparov toujours premier je crois
qu'il a perdu un ou deux points il a
perdu deux points
on a perdu deux points il n'est plus
qu'à 2 1849 même en gagnant tous ses
tours noir mais parce qu'il a fait
tellement de résultats extraordinaires
que pour qu'il gagne des points
maintenant puisqu'il à 2849 c'est un
record historique encore totalement
historique et ça jamais j'ai jamais lu
ce qu'il faut savoir aussi c'est que
derrière tous les jours on va en parler
mais tous les joueurs derrière soit en
dessous du record de fisher qui tenait
depuis 72 2780
95 je crois ou 90 alors je ne sais pas
trop c'était 85 pour moi les loteries
cher n'a jamais été publié enfin si donc
pour moi fischer n'a jamais eu des lots
en tout cas bon petit c'est à 85,02
fischer en 72 d'accords mets donc ça
mais aucun des joueurs ne rattrapent les
lots historique de fisher qui avait pas
été battue pendant vingt ans il ya
cocasse porte qu'il a battu mais il a
carrément défoncer comme wallace et 2008
oui c'est de la boucherie puisque le
deuxième mondial c'est donc vladimir
kramnik qui est passé devant ammann
brille surfer entre guillemets puisque
on pouvait s'y attendre un peu tourné
linares on y les deux joueurs continuent
à se tenir quand même de trail de traits
d'assez près chronique faits +12 une
belle progression est donc se retrouve
deuxième mais à 2770 c'est à dire pas
loin de 80 points derrière kasparov sont
énormes c'est vraiment énorme
80 points il faut savoir que c'est c'est
terrible quand comme différence de
joueurs à 100 points des lots différence
il n'y a pas de match quoi ces 80 points
bas c'est la différence entre le
deuxième et le 100e mondiale ouais c'est
pour dire oui c'est vraiment une
différence tout à fait énorme donc garry
kasparov toujours impressionnant mais
enfin bon ça sert plus à rien le
commenter puisque il est toujours là
avec le même classement donc garé t'es
sport toujours premiers krainik deuxième
maintenant tu passes devant 1 2769
devant le 3 c'est bien parce que ça
justifie le match kasparov cramique plus
que s'ils ramenaient qui était troisième
oui enfin ce qu'il faudrait vraiment
pour justifier un match des spurs
kramnik c'est encore la fameuse dérive
vers c'est le championnat du monde qui
nous guette
pour éviter enfin pour justifier le
challenger de kasparov il faudra
organiser des matchs un circuit complet
en tout cas quelque chose qui ressemble
à quelque chose c'est vrai en tout cas
mon agent ne perd qu'une place
troisième avec 2762 ça fait du bien ne
pas avoir un russe dans les premiers
parce que si les indiens
parce qu'à la 4e on retrouve un russe me
retrouve morose et beach à 2756 qui
gagne encore 8 points elo donc
morozevich qui a fait une performance en
demi-teinte enfin une bonne performance
à sarajevo qui gagne encore des points
je crois qu'il a gagné des partis en
équipe
c'est ça qui lui a valu cette cette
augmentation de points mais terriblement
des vitrines il est très fort puisque
2756 il est seulement à 6 points d'un
monde
c'est dire qu'en fait il se rapproche
vraiment de la troisième place convient
de rappeler que bon début c'était la
grosse surprise à l'année dernière on
n'avait jamais entendu parler quasiment
il avait fait d'excellents résultats en
espagne beaucoup d' open on avait parlé
de sa victoire à pampelune où il a fait
un de résultats fabuleux je crois qu'ils
avaient fait 9 sur 9 août jusqu'en 2000
effet un résultat canon way et il se
retrouve maintenant à confirmer
largement puisque depuis qu'il est dans
le top 10 il n'en sort pas et non
seulement bien sûr pas mais ils gagnent
des places
il ya eu des places il est dangereux
parce qu'en plus il est jeune il a il a
23 ou 24 ans oui plutôt 23 et non c'est
un c'est un très très bon joueur très
jeune donc évidemment à une encore une
marge de progression très élevé donc
peut-être un successeur peut-être en
successeur on parle beaucoup de akram
ricanant de l'éco shirov un peu moins
parce qu'il ya déjà un peu plus âgées
mais morose et vite mais j'ai vite il
est là et il avance aux écrans qu'ils
ont et 5e places encore un mec qui
avance encore quelqu'un qui avance avant
lui par contre il a fait un excellent
début de saison
un excellent je crois qu'on peut dire il
a fait un tournoi de sarajevo fabuleux
oui ben je crois qu'il est terminé
second c'est un sanguin à une demi point
kasparov à égalité avec shirov qui perd
le tournoi bêtement sur la fin et qui
fait savoir qu'elle soit enfin tout à
fait incroyable sarah niveau aussi il ya
gagné ses trois dernières parties enfin
un résultat positif incroyable et adams
a fait un très très bon résultat faut
rappeler aussi qu'il a gagné le grand
prix de bordeaux bruyamment
fait 4 sur 4 en équipe 4 sur 4 ans
linking enfin en équipe championne de
france par équipes donc il a fait un
très bon résultat afin de voir aussi
voyant mon premier avec +7 tu crois
c'est énorme
donc adams en superforme super adams
donc qui pointe à la cinquième place
mondiale avec 2755 soit une progression
de 40 points
c'est vrai c'est énorme c'est à 40.5
voit jamais simple ça veut dire qu'il a
fait une performance à peu près à 2850
je pense ou quelque chose comme ça sur
les parties qu'il a jouées et la 1.2
monde évite uniquement un point de
marseille 4e en fait ils se tiennent
tous ces jours il ya un paquet de
joueurs qui se tiennent jusqu'à
justement peter l'écho c'est à dire que
après adams en numéro 6 il ya shirov qui
a perdu quelques points qui a perdu cinq
points mais qui perd pas de place par
contre 2700 46e stable à la 6e place
reste stable bon set peter l'écho qui
gagnent un peu de points qu'il gagne 18
points mais bon au pire l'écho donc
voilà le top 6 et là c'est le tournoi de
linares le et donc puisqu'elle in eyes
peter les collines arrêt cela il se
retrouve ses adams qui passe devant
gérard adams était 7e et en les côtés
devant shirov donc l'écossé curieux mais
hélicopère déplace en ayant gagné des
points parce qu adam c'est shirov donc
20 gagnait plus que lui d'accord
d'accord d'accord donc ici enfin en tout
cas on allait s'immergeant les sept
meilleurs joueurs mondiaux
ça c'est une certitude ensuite ils vont
tous bretons pas l'offre et surprise 10e
place grâce à une offre qui passe au
dessus des 2750 moi je connaissais pas
c'est un joueur polonais n'est pas connu
effectivement dans le sud de la france
en seine dont on peut pas demi surprise
parce que c'est que bon voilà lé top 10
sauf en tout cas n'avait pas l'habitude
de le voir là en tout cas parmi les
joueurs d'échecs krasnenkov est
extrêmement respectée puisque c'est un
moment très très bon joueur un excellent
théoricien avec des nerfs assez solides
ils avaient battu à nantes dans une très
belle partie
il a déjà fait une
une forte progression et lorsqu'il est
propulsé dans un super tournoi vous
l'avez fait une belle prestation très il
prend la place de barrières qui étaient
étaient dans le top 10 1 et donc on
remarque que notre ami karpov ne revient
plus non mais je crois que la note une
carpe
il définit les parties il dort il a fait
une deuxième il a fait deuxième au
tournoi de au [ __ ] sa classique de
derrière judit polgar ils ont fait boire
un bon tournoi bon mais c'est clair
qu'ils vont il n'est plus aussi combatif
qu'avant mais bon sur un match il peut
il reste il reste extrêmement fort en
anatolie
si tu nous regardes autant pour nous
anatolie voilà les français peut-être
maintenant un petit peu ou alors les
français évidemment le classement
français avec la première classe du
classement français mini pas français
mais comme il vit en france il est
classé en france c'est ladislav quatre
chefs qu'on a vu à bordeaux 1 d'ailleurs
on va trouver pas mal de joueurs comme
jouer à bordeaux puisque en deuxième on
trouve derrière katja joël lautier
bijoux abandon avec des élus respectifs
donc de 2 857 et de 1648 ce qui les
place dans les 30 meilleurs joueurs
mondiaux 30 et 40 qui a perdu des points
malheureusement puisqu'il a perdu 13
points donc ça c'est pas suite ces
matches il avait un peu craqué voilà en
championnat de france par équipes ça lui
a coûté cher la dernière phase il a
perdu deux parties de suite
et hop ça ne pardonne pas quand on à
2670 en tout cas donc quatre chefs faire
quelques points lautier en gagnent 16
ans suit notre petit français etienne
indienne viennent bosser coin puisqu'il
était un peu en dessous de 2006
ça y est le 819 je crois qu'il est au
dessus donc c'est la première fois c'est
historique
il passe au dessus des 2600 et c'est
historique et fiction aucun elle a
confirmé qu' ils tiennent à que 17 ans
donc on peut supposer que s'il continue
sur cette trajectoire dans trois ans
quatre ans il peut arriver dans les 20
meilleurs mondiaux voire dans les 10 6
s'il fait un palier supplémentaire
là il faut il ya encore une étape à
franchir quand on voit quand on voit le
niveau des joueurs est malheureusement
etienne pour l'instant n'est pas assez
fort ou lorsqu on peut noter alors on
retrouve dorfman derrière sokolov bon ça
c'est des immigrés russes
donc ils sont français maintenant
d'ailleurs on peut noter un dry sokolov
naturalisé français depuis pas longtemps
oui tout à fait par contre le premier
français disons de culture française de
culture africaine française c'est
christian bauer quelle fin qui fait un
score impressionnant c'est ça faisait
longtemps drain français à ce niveau là
derrière 2762 2562 a effectivement on a
vu où jean-marc degraeve qui était
arrivé à 2580 mais ça n'avait pas duré
christian bauer eelv à 2562 mais ça a
l'air d'être un classement qui lui va
bien je pense qu'il a vraiment progressé
beaucoup
baïla il a été qualifié pour las vegas
il a fait un bon tournoi je crois qu'il
avait il est perdu contre peter l'écho
au deuxième tour en dehors donc c'est
pas mal et avec emile zola avait gagné
zonal puis actuellement non il fait les
championnats d'europe je crois que
l'individuel non ce sera le prochain
sujet de notre actualitté se débrouille
pas mal
après on trouve spassky qu'on a eu le
plaisir de voir autrement du sénat qui
est toujours là bon mais il joue plus
mais boris mais il garde son classement
oui tout à fait normal et les autres
joueurs n'ont à peu près en gros pas
bougé la grosse surprise au niveau
français c'est christian bauer est bien
trop qui passe au dessus des 6 mois je
crois que laurent frayssinet aussi
impressionnant parce que ça saute dessus
2005 il avait déjà plus 2005 il avait
déjà mais l'admission 36 il confirme il
progresse donc il a on peut dire que
maintenant il a le niveau d'un grand
maître il ne manque plus qu'à faire les
normes pour devenir grand maître et donc
il est en tout cas ça fait plaisir de
voir que le nôtre vice champion du monde
passe il faut pas oublier qu'il est
quand même vice champion du monde cadet
et bien confirme et donc
progresse tranquillement il fait son
bonhomme de chemin quoi donc là on va
d'ailleurs on va retrouver nos français
dans notre deuxième sujet de ses news
c'est le tournoi le championnat d'europe
individuel donc qui a lieu en italie à
saint vincent dans le val d'aoste
si je si je ne me trompe pas donc
rapidement en bref pour terminer cette
émission en tête après trois rondes
thierry gaiffe bon c'est très très fort
c'est un tournoi extrêmement fort il ya
pavel très bobo enfin savoir que les
deux premiers sont qualifiés pour le
prochain championnat du monde de la
fédération qui aura lieu en deux parties
à new delhi et altérant fins d'impôts ce
qui est annoncé en tout cas en fin
d'année donc les deux premiers de ce
championnat d'europe sont qualifiés
directement
mais on peut se qualifier d'autres
bordeaux ton face aux grands réseaux
nationaux johann tarification spéciale
dont gorguette premier très gros beauf
deuxième galkin le russe qu'on avait vu
à lausanne c'était non l'ancien champion
du monde junior ou peut-être même le
champion du monde junior en titre
quelques une troisième place pour
l'instant krasnenkov la grosse
progression avec 2700 2e au classement
donc il ya deux points et demi sur trois
et les français donc christian bauer
deux points et demi sur 3 également donc
il est en tête des français laurent
frayssinet de points bof pas terrible
alberto david qui luxembourgeois mais
qu'on effectivement qu'on considère
comme un français puisqu'il habite en
france depuis très longtemps
deux points également et si l île
marcellin qui a fait normes de grand
maître
une fois qu'on a reçus a dit ronald on
peut le trouver dans les différer cyril
marcellin un point et demi qui a perdu
contre siège kickoff le grand maître
russe donc voilà notre français bauer
freyssinet marcellin des jeunes c'est
une sélection française à ces jeunes qui
va là bas donc affaire à suivre toute
façon compte rendu non pas la semaine
prochaine puisque je crois qu'il a pas
d'émission et pas d'émission à semaine
prochaine une émission dans deux
semaines avec une spéciale dortmund
spéciale de reconstruire puisque la
semaine prochaine c'est malheureusement
notre fête nationale
voilà parcours spécial de route avec un
reportage donc en direct de dortmund
fait par éloi et jean-luc chavanon
jean-luc chavanon qui sera là donc pour
en finir
qui sera là pour la leçon lundi c'est à
dire dans quatre dans trois jours lundi
10 au matin il sera là et qui commentera
une partie donc très positionnelle mans
avec son style habituel
voilà je l'aï jamais non merci de nous
avoir suivis merci de nous avoir suivis
et donc à des enquêtes de jours
m
oh